the Joe Rogan experience well
skateboarding too it's it's almost like
some people would think of it as a
frivolous activity sure like yeah
glorious results of a misspent youth if
you know how to around a skateboard yeah
it's funny the um when I first started I
have a foundation for public skate parks
we've been gone 20 years actually how
does that were they well we we basically
give communities the resources to get a
part going like if they if someone in
the community has started a petition or
fundraising or just raising awareness
that they need a park we sort of give
them the roadmap to do that and funding
to do it
oh that's somebody um and you know
designed help and things like that so
it's been great we've we've helped to
fund over 900 skate parks now all 50
states we've given away almost ten
million dollars that's incredible yeah I
mean it's definitely my proudest work
but but when when I started it there was
a point where I was we were trying to
get funding and trying to raise
awareness and you know I'm doing I'm
doing visits to children's cancer wards
and stuff like that and at some point I
was like I'm trying to build skate parks
and I remember this conversation I had
very vividly actually with Lance
Armstrong when and this is when he was
the face of cancer research you know
what I mean like say what you all about
his competitive career but he did so
much free cancer awareness and research
and I'm visiting Children's Hospital
with Lance Armstrong and when Lance
often walks into a cancer ward back then
like the Seas part you know I mean it
was just like this it was like oh he's
here and I remember having lunch with
him that day and I was like it's so
weird to be with you you're you're doing
so much for cancer and cancer victims
and I'm just trying to build playgrounds
yeah like you know concrete waves and he
said he said look the the the number one
cause of cancer or numbered you know
number two cause of cancer in the u.s.
is obesity and by building those skate
parks you are preventing cancer
you're preventing obesity Wow and that
was heavy for me that is heavy and and
it really gave me a lot of inspiration
you know and a lot more motivation where
you're creating a potential place for
joy right and in for beat you know for
it for people to like-minded people to
hang out like to develop a community I
mean when I was a kid like I felt like
an outcast I felt like like I didn't
belong in in sports I didn't belong in
my school and when I went to the skate
park and there was this band of misfits
listening to punk music and look you
know weird hairdos from all walks of
life I was like this is it this is my
crew and I want the same sense of
community for you know we're not trying
to build training grounds for Olympians
we're just trying to build a place for
them to feel like they belong and feel
like their community actually cares
about them yeah and it is a loved
pursuit I mean even though it's had
these weird views like or people's had
have had weird views about it if you
think about how many people love it and
how it requires this sort of a place
like what you're creating right to
really do it right in nowadays it's way
different now that the the sort of
perspective on skating or the attitude
towards skating is that parents are
doing with their kids like you know and
little girls are encouraged to try it
and that just wasn't the case when I was
a kid like my think it's because of you
in a lot of ways oh well thank you I
mean I've I was always happy to at least
advocate for skating and try to explain
to people like this has a real positive
impact on kids you're look you you're
you're too focused on the hairdos and
the music and stuff you got to really
look at what it provides someone's
mentality yeah but that's always been
the case with things that kids do that
their parents didn't do sure like how
many parents told their kids to stop
playing video games and now kids are
literally making millions of dollars
playing video games and parents have to
kind of make this adjustment like okay
yeah okay so I think the generation of
parents now grew up at a time when
skating was starting to
be cool yeah okay so either they're
encouraging of their kids skating or
they're actually skating with them
that's awesome that's gotta make you
feel good which is very cool yeah impact
on the thing that you love yeah I mean
the coolest part is for me is that I
still get to participate and I get to
bear witness to all this
[Applause]